wayne johnson is giving back to his
former high schools in honolulu and in
pennsylvania by donating sports gear to
the football teams through his project
rock initiative with under armour the
rock delivered an inspiring speech via
video message and later surprised
students with all new gear ahead of
their homecoming love that yeah take a
look
my fellow freedom patriots
my fellow gridiron brothers uh i know
that it's homecoming i know that you
guys are enjoying your pregame meal
right now i hope the food is good it
looked good from all the pictures that i
saw and i know that parents and families
are cooking up these meals for you guys
every week uh with a lot of effort
obviously a lot of care and certainly a
lot of luck and i want to send you guys
a little message i want to tell you guys
a few things number one i wanted to tell
you how proud i am of you guys here's
why i'm proud i'm proud of the hard work
you put in because that's what it all
comes down to whether you win or lose
succeed or fail it all comes down to the
effort that you put in and the hard work
that you commit yourselves to
i want you to think about how you want
to be remembered on the field how you
want to be remembered throughout the
halls of freedom high school look you
know i walked those halls of freedom
high sophomore year junior year senior
year as all of you know we worked our
asses off in the weight room uh off
season uh during the season we worked
our asses off in the classroom and we
always talked about back then like how
do we want to be remembered how do we
want to be remembered how does this
class want to be remembered how do our
seniors want to be remembered walking
these halls of freedom high
you know doing a lot of things i
shouldn't have been doing in those halls
but that doesn't matter
a couple of detentions listen that's not
important the most important thing is i
want you guys to think about that how
you want to be remembered because it's
your performance it's your commitment uh
that that lives on forever
so
uh i have a surprise for you guys i have
a company that i partnered with under
armour and that company is called
project rock
and project rock our training gear
football gear
uh workout gear fitness gear
uh we have become under armour's number
one seller and uh myself project rock
and under armour wanted to give you guys
and gear you up uh the right way before
the game tomorrow
so enjoy your gifts and i'm proud of you
keep up the great work have a great rest
of the season